Alright. We're just testing
out these Lenovo laptops.
Yeah. They're the really tough ones
used by NASA in space.
Yeah. We're told they're
actually 64 ThinkPads
on the international
space station right now.
They used to use them
for their shuttle missions.
Alright. So they've got
a lot to live up to
bouncing around the space
for a while
Yeah.
Do things bounce in space?
Yeah. Yeah, they do.
Yeah. Well, in that case,
we should use a combination
of our high speed camera
and my next door neighbor's trampoline
to simulate zero gravity with laptops.
Is that all the real astronauts do?
Yes. Yes it is.
Let's go.
So how is this anything by being in space?
Well, if you're falling
at the same speed as the laptop
and the camera's panning at the same speed
following you down,
it'll give you the illusion of you
floating in space
with a laptop.
What?
Just jump up and down.
Yeah. I can see myself
checking my space emails on this.
Yeah.
S W W dot
S W W dot?
Space wide web isn't it?
Oh, space wide web.
Yeah. Do you get YouTube in space?
You must be able to.
I bet the astronauts
watch the Slow Mo guys
in space all the time.
What else are they doing up there?
So apparently this ThinkPad
are designed to meet many
military specifications for toughness,
like serious vibration,
dust, thermal shock,
hot and cold temperatures.
And that's before
They have been flown up to space as well.
I think we should get
some liquids involved.
are they water resistant?
Yes they are. Let's go.
Mug of water.
love how you almost drowned
I like how desperately hard
you're trying to
trick your space a little there
you are just like
I really need a sip over
my mouth and everything.
I was like
screw the laptop
you still have to do everything at once
Let's see how the,
the laptop has faired
after being mug of watered.
our test is going to
be playing this video?
All right I think we've got to
step it up to the next level.
I love doing that. Wobbly.
Right in the damn jugular.
So typical space situation.
Isn't it?
Often.
The killer space bullet.
You launched that.
So not only did the laptop survive that
it saved you from getting wet.
Yeah
So well.
Bucket. Three, two, one. Now.
Wow that was wet.
Here it comes master shooter
Oh, that looks really
like abstract. Doesn't it?
Yeah, looks like a
Like a soap unfreezing
I'm still dripping.
How did you get so wet
from one bucket of water?
That's how there
Oh yeah.
You, see wet
I wonder if I'm asked
to save my documents,
Still managing
I saw you just press control.
Saved
Let's try mug water
straight on the keyboard.
All right. Let's do a little video test
Still plays like a dream
It just had a mug of water
pour on it.
That's cool. That's pretty cool actually.
Each one, each key has a globe of water.
That was an exciting test.
The slight continuity
and that the sun is gone away.
You're completely dry.
I've dried out a little bit.
Yeah
Still a little bit wet.
Can't do much about the sun,
but what'd you get,
you're going to wet again.
What?
Glad the shorts match now.
I'd probably check my underwater
emails with this.
So what you ww dot.
Underwater wear.
Yeah.
Well, I'm amazed that these laptops
have actually survived every test
we dropped him
one fell off the trampoline
and they've been so,
but still work just great. So,
It's pretty impressive.
Yeah. Pretty impressive.
We can keep these laptops, right?
Yeah.
Good.Sweet.